okay it's only this whole it's the  notion of a man you know caring so much  to look through but I think I would say  like this if you felt like he was gonna  you was with her for a while and you  weren't really and you felt like  something was up  I understand why certain men do  personally I wouldn't just because I  don't even want to feel what's on that  side so if I feel something's up I'll  just walk I'm just like that now yeah  but um sometimes sometimes it's not that  deep especially like when you feel sorry  like really feel something for her you  might be thinking you know let me not  make the crazy part let me just see if  it's actually if it's not then babe I'm  sorry but then when you do because I've  been in that situation I actually came  across what I thought it was you do end  up going on the crazy side of it because  you end up feeding into what what you  originally thought yeah